you
I'm looking for the magic thumbs up told
me we're live on candid camera not
candid camera I got it all right
well welcome everyone my name is Jeff
eisenach and I'm a visiting scholar here
at the American Enterprise Institute
it's a wonderful pleasure for us today
to welcome FCC Chairman Ajit PI to the
American Enterprise Institute over the
course well I've known Ajit for some
years but over the course of the past
several months I've had the opportunity
to get to know him better in my role as
part of the Trump transition team for
the Federal Communications Commission
and when people ask me about that I tell
them that of all of the various
transition teams for the Trump
transition
I had the lightest lift of all and
that's because we had these two
wonderful Republican commissioners
present and in place at the FCC and
people would ask me what would the Trump
what would the Trump administration's
communications policy agenda be after
the inauguration and I said well don't
ask me go to the FCC website and read
the dissents of a GTI and mike o'reilly
over the course of the past few years
and you'll see you'll see it spelled out
in with tremendous substance and detail
i want to talk for just a second about a
Jeets accomplishments over the past 100
and two days obviously there's some
controversial issues in front of the
Commission but there's some issues but
front of the Commission which ought to
be at least ought to be less
controversial on ajit has taken those on
with at a pace and with a level of
substance and success far more akin to
an internet startup than a typical
Washington moribund bureaucracy first of
all jeet has put in place common-sense
procedural reforms like making notices
orders public before they're voted on by
the committee
what a concept you thought that could
have happened before revoking the staffs
editorial privileges so after the
commission votes on something the staff
now actually has to carry out what the
Commission voted on instead of rewriting
it under historical editorial privileges
and and many of these are bipartisan and
and including another one being simply
telling the staff that when a
commissioner even a commissioner from
the other political party asks you for
information about a proceeding or
something going on at the Commission you
should answer the question now you would
think that's all just good government
but it is the antithesis of the previous
four years under the previous chairman
who we won't name here
chairman PI has also taken a weedwacker
to the regulatory underbrush
little-noticed
changes eliminating unnecessary
paperwork requirements and at the other
end of the spectrum actually requiring
that companies applying for government
subsidies demonstrate their bona fide
ease to receive those subsidies and
spend them in a responsible way would
another concept on the substantive front
it's been changed after change after
change all of them in the spirit of
another FCC Chairman 17 years ago
chairman bill canard who spoke
eloquently about the need to create an
FCC for the 21st century to clean out
the regulatory underbrush to move from a
system of silos and heavy-handed ex-ante
regulation to a competition based
framework an enforcement based framework
of ex post regulation consistent with
the increasing competitiveness of the
telecommunications marketplace and on
issue after issue chairman PI has moved
that agenda along including the very
visible issues which I'm sure we'll get
into today but also less visible issues
something as important as beginning the
process of deregulating the marketplace
for business data services which is
essentially the Internet backbone
services and
and which is and has been competitive
we're finally going to get around to
deep regulating that and something is
you might think mundane or technical as
beginning the process of permitting
lte-u into the marketplace allowing new
technologies to be rolled out without
the heavy hand of government slowing
innovation so I've talked long enough
I'm not going to give a long
introduction of Ajit
he is currently chairman of the Federal
Communications Commission previously he
was a member of the Federal
Communications Commission prior to that
he served in the General Counsel's
office at the Federal Communications
Commission his dedication to the agency
I think is an important part of his
success and it's it's worth I think
going back and looking at his first
speech as chairman which was to the
staff of the agency reassuring them that
his purpose is to advance the agency and
its professional staff not to attack it
and I think that's been another
component of his chairmanship that's
been so important lest we forget
Ajit graduated from Harvard University
he received his law degree from the
University of Chicago where he was
editor of the Law Review and so we are
dealing not only with a great leader but
a tremendous intellect GPI thank you for
in here
thank you Jeff for those very kind words
thanks to the entire team at AEI for
putting this event together Jeff I
especially appreciate the comparison to
a former chairman bill canard
distinguished public servant and someone
I can now call a friend to be mentioned
even the same sentence as the Chairman
canard is a high honor indeed it is
great to be back here at the American
Enterprise Institute being here today
reminds me that 2016 was a time of great
change in Washington looking back it's
clear that we witnessed a momentous
event one that I'm sure caused many
people some consternation
I brought tremendous joy to others and
quite a lot of people to pack up with
their offices and move out referring of
course to AEI z-- decision to move into
this wonderful new space after many
years on 17th Street congratulations on
the on the move
but in all seriousness AEI and its
scholars have done tremendous work by
making the case for expanding freedom
for extending individual opportunity and
for strengthening America's free
enterprise system and in particular a
EEI has shown thought leadership on
communications policy and much if not
most of the credit for that goes to Jeff
Eisen aku has really done so much work
over the years including during the
transition that he mentioned so thank
you Jeff for your scholarship for your
friendship and for your counsel earlier
this week as Jeff pointed out we reached
the 100 day mark as my tenure of my
tenure as chairman sure doesn't feel
like a hundred days I have to tell you
it's a time flys much more quickly in
this job than it did when I was in the
minority but by any objective measure
we've hit the ground running and we have
had a very productive three plus months
at the FCC here just one data point for
your consideration too in my first 100
days the FCC adopted 49 items they have
to put that number in perspective during
the prior to permanent Chairman's first
100 days the Commission adopted 25 and
34 items I know what you're thinking as
legendary UCLA basketball coach
wooden once said never mistake activity
for achievement so I thought it would be
helpful this morning to highlight some
of the actions we've taken in to explain
how they fit into a broader strategic
vision and that vision includes five
goals that are important to me and
hopefully to you number one closing the
digital divide
number two modernizing our rules number
three promoting innovation number four
protecting consumers and public safety
and number five improving the agency's
operations these are the goals that I've
emphasized since I arrived at the FCC
almost exactly five years ago today
these are the goals that have shaped and
animated my first 100 days as chairman
and these are the goals that I hope will
be the agency's beacon in the years to
come let's start with closing the
digital divide on my first full day as
chairman has Jeff pointed out I
delivered remarks to the agency's
fantastic and talented staff and I
focused on one issue bringing the
benefits of the digital age to all
Americans
this principle goes back to the
Commission's founding statute section 1
to the Communications Act of 1934
charged the FCC with making
communications services available so far
as possible to all the people of the
United States and to me at least this
mission is more vital than ever
after all broadband opens doors to
opportunity in almost every aspect of
modern American life whether it's
looking for a job getting medical care
doing your homework keeping in touch
with friends and family or engaging with
your favorites regulators that was a
joke actually I'm here all week but
broadband is also given rise to what
I've called the democratization of
entrepreneurship with a powerful plan
and a digital connection you can raise
capital you can start a business you can
hire people and you can reach a global
customer base from anywhere in America
and so I believe that every American who
wants to participate in our digital
economy should be able to do so access
to digital opportunities should not
depend on who you are where you live
you look like or where you're from but
to be clear we are not where we need to
be if you live in rural America you are
much less likely to have high-speed
Internet access than if you live in a
city if you live in a low-income
neighborhood you are much less likely to
have high-speed Internet access than if
you live in a wealthier area the digital
divide in our country is real and it is
persistent it makes it harder for many
of our fellow American citizens to
improve their lives and it takes a
significant toll on America's economy
and our global competitiveness when I
became chairman the FCC needed to step
up its efforts to close this gap and
that is exactly what we've done
my first two meetings as FCC chairman
involved conversations with consumer
advocates and small broadband providers
on ways to promote digital empowerment
my very first vote is chairman was to
partner with the state of New York to
deliver 170 million dollars for
broadband deployment in upstate areas
where residents have been bypassed for
far too long and the first Commission
meeting for which I had the power to set
the agenda featured two significant
measures to expand broadband access in
unserved areas one was an order passed
unanimously to bring mobile broadband to
millions of Americans through what is
known as the mobility fund phase two
previously the FCC was spending about
twenty five million dollars a month of
taxpayer money to subsidize wireless
carriers in areas where private capital
was already doing the job we are
redirecting that spending and more four
point five three billion dollars over
the next decade in order to bring 4G LTE
service to rural Americans who don't
have it today and we're doing it in an
efficient fiscally responsible way by
using a competitive reverse auction to
allocate those funds now at the same
meeting we decided again on a bipartisan
basis to move forward with two billion
dollars in wired broadband investment
through what's called phase two of our
connect America fund here too we set up
a competitive bidding process to get the
most bang for the buck in terms of
bringing high-speed Internet access to
currently unserved rural Americans our
for this auction will encourage a wide
range of entities to compete and to
participate from wireless internet
service providers to electric utilities
now these two capital investment plans
will bring internet access to many
unserved Americans and they'll put
Americans to work building next
generation networks in rural America but
these were just parts of the opening
acts
our most recent FCC meeting included
three initiatives designed to make it
easier for companies to build and expand
high-speed broadband networks we
launched again unanimously a proceeding
to lower costs and speed the deployment
of new wireline infrastructure to speed
up the transition from copper networks
to moderate modern fighter in bur
networks this means that more money will
be spent on the resilient technologies
of tomorrow not the fading networks of
yesterday and we launched yet again
unanimously a proceeding to facilitate
the deployment of the hundreds of
thousands of small cells that will power
the 5g networks of tomorrow and we
eliminated still yet again unanimously a
rule that needlessly penalized rural
carriers telephone companies for
deploying broadband to certain parts of
their communities looking ahead we also
want to explore fresh ideas for tackling
the long-standing challenge of this
digital divide and to that end we
created the broadband deployment
Advisory Committee a panel of experts to
make recommendations to the FCC about
strategies to promote better and faster
and cheaper broadband over three hundred
and eighty two individuals applied to
serve on this committee representing
community groups community organizations
and custom consumer organizations
government and Industry a diverse and
highly impressive pool of applicants we
recently invited 29 individuals to serve
on this committee alleged by the highly
talented Elizabeth Pearce of the CEO of
Qin Chilean networks and Kelly Cole of
the Utah broadband Outreach Center the
bedeck as we call it held its first
meeting last month and I expect it will
make a major difference in our work to
connect all Americans now some of the
actions we've taken to spur broadband
deployment and to close the digital
find dovetail with our second major
priority which is modernizing the
Commission's rules and eliminating
unnecessary regulatory burdens you often
hear about how regulatory red tape
imposes real costs and stifles
investment and innovation here's one
statistic that gives you a sense of how
real and how significant those costs are
according to the Office of Management
and Budget the FCC imposes 800 million
dollars each and every year
in paperwork burdens that's right 800
million dollars each year this doesn't
count the money that people must spend
paying workers to fill out all of this
paperwork and again these are only the
FCC's paperwork burdens that I'm talking
about the total regulatory burden that
the FCC places on the private sector is
actually much higher than that to me at
least the fundamental question is this
do we want that money to be diverted to
lawyers and accountants figuring out how
to comply with the FCC's regulatory
requirements or do we want it to be
spent delivering American consumers
better and faster and cheaper Internet
access
no offense to my friends in the
communications Bart but to me at least
the answer to that question is pretty
clear a paperwork aside we are reviewing
the FCC's rules across the board and
deciding which one still makes sense in
the digital age as part of this review
we're asking whether the costs of a rule
outweigh the benefits when the facts
weren't we will not hesitate to revise
overly burdensome rules or to repeal
them altogether you don't need a
weatherman to know that the wind is
blowing certain FCC rules towards
modification or elimination and that's
especially true by the way for small
businesses federal regulations have a
disproportionate effect on these
companies and these companies remember
are often the linchpin to a more
competitive marketplace and they don't
have the compliance resources to
withstand a regulatory onslaught I'm
very sensitive to the impact that our
regulations can have on such businesses
and that's why in my first week as
chairman I proposed to relieve small
Internet service providers from costly
and overly burdensome reporting
requirements associated with the title
to order and we did that in February
and this is just one example of many
that illustrate how we are modernizing
our rules we also relaxed unnecessary
command and control regulations for
business data services to create greater
incentives for the private sector to
invest in next-generation networks we
streamlined various accounting
requirements for many wireline carriers
requirements that literally require them
to maintain two different sets of books
we eased reporting burdens for volunteer
board members of non commercial
broadcasters we updated our
interpretation of our Equal Employment
Opportunity rules to account for the
ways that people actually look for jobs
today and we eliminated two filing
requirements broadcasters public
correspondents files and cable operators
principal head in locations that no
longer made any sense now I recognize
that as I go through this litany these
decisions and others like them might
seem like small potatoes but remember
what former Senate Minority Leader
Everett Dirksen once had to say about
spending a billion here a billion there
and pretty soon you're talking real
money so - as we go about eliminating a
rule here and rule there we will end up
substantially adjusting our rules to
match the realities of the modern
marketplace and that is something that
is good for consumers and good for
companies alike now the third key FCC
priority I mentioned is promoting
innovation across the communications
industry I might be new to the
chairmanship but I have served on the
Commission as I said for almost half a
decade and during that time I have had
the great privilege of traveling all
across this country and to all corners
of the land and I can report firsthand
that the entrepreneurial spirit is alive
and well in America just this March I
took my first road trip as chairman
visiting Pittsburgh and Youngstown and
Cleveland and Detroit along the way I
met with an incredible array of startups
a mobile app company that is already
helping 80 million people around the
world learn new languages for free the
virtual reality gaming entrepreneur a
new online platform to provide treatment
for people with addiction
and many many more like them I also stab
that visited established entities like
the Cleveland Clinic where I witnessed a
demonstration of a mobile stroke unit
that is using new technology to cut the
time needed to assess and stabilize a
stroke patient by an average of 38
minutes critical minutes when you
consider that the brain for a stroke
patient loses two million cells every
single minute whether it's someone
tinkering in a small town garage or a
growing company in a major technology
hub we at the FCC want to help American
entrepreneurs bring these big ideas to
life and that's why we've put in place a
process to implement at long last
section 7 of the Communications Act a
long-neglected law going forward if an
innovator or inventor files a petition
or application at the FCC for the
approval of a new technology or service
we will abide by the law and we will
make a decision within one year there
will be no more waiting indefinitely for
an answer as the old saying goes tell me
yes tell me no or just tell me something
now that's why we've changed our
experimental licensing program and we've
launched a new website to make it easier
for parties to register proposed new
experiments this new type of
experimental license will allow greater
flexibility for parties including
universities and research labs and
healthcare facilities and manufacturers
of radio frequency equipment to develop
their technologies and services while
protecting incumbents services against
harmful interference that's why as Jeff
pointed out we authorized the first-ever
LTE unlicensed devices in the five
gigahertz band a significant advance for
wireless innovation and spectrum sharing
this gives wireless consumers the best
of both worlds a more robust and
seamless networks when their phones are
relying on cellular networks and the
continued enjoyment of Wi-Fi and that's
why we began the process of allowing
television broadcasters to fully enter
the digital age
by using the next-generation television
standard on a voluntary market-driven
basis this new transmission standard
known as ATSC 3.0 is the first one to
marry the advantages of broadcasting and
the Internet
and it could lead broadcasters offer
much better services in various ways
4k transmissions immersive audio better
accessibility options and much much more
now one more point about our approach to
promoting innovation we want to
encourage innovation throughout the
internet economy and that means
innovation not just at the edge of the
networks but also innovation at the core
of those networks within the network's
themselves also we want to encourage
business model innovation and more
options for consumers that's a big
reason why we closed the FCC's
investigation into free data offerings
Wireless companies offering consumers
something for free has shockingly proven
popular among consumers especially
low-income Americans and it's also made
the wireless marketplace more
competitive than ever going forward
the FCC will seek to promote not to
prevent that kind of innovation and that
leads to our fourth guiding priority
which is protecting consumers and that
goes hand-in-hand with promoting public
safety the most effective tool for
protecting consumers is a competitive
marketplace but as we've seen
competition sometimes is enough is not
enough to guard consumers against scams
and other unsavory practices when
consumers feel they are being taken
advantage of they often turn to the FCC
for help and this FCC is taking action
the number one source of consumer
complaints at the FCC in for many years
has been robo calls we've all
experienced them during our daily lives
and here the agency has moved
aggressively to save Americans from the
scourge of Rachel from cardholder
services and many of her friends we have
sought to give providers more leeway to
block calls that use a spoofed caller ID
number and that seemed to be from an
unassigned or invalid phone number this
would impede the illegitimate callers
and these scam artists who often engage
in call spoofing and prey upon some of
our most vulnerable populations we've
also taken action to protect consumers
many of whom are small businesses from
scams
for instance we levied a 1 million
dollar fine against a florida-based long
diss
carrier for impersonating
representatives of customers existing
long distance providers and illegally
switching the customers long distance
carriers now another area where the this
FCC has made a mark is in ensuring that
communication services are accessible to
Americans with disabilities
for instance we have already taken steps
to improve the quality and the
efficiency of video relay services these
are services that help people who are
deaf hard of hearing or speech disabled
communicate our reforms will encourage
more competition and they will help make
these services more useful and
meaningful to disabled Americans in
their daily lives public safety is
another dimension of consumer protection
again this is a principle that is rooted
in our founding statute which charges
the FCC with protecting the safety of
life and property for communications one
area in which we've delivered results
involves the problem of contraband
cellphones these devices are being
smuggled into prisons and jails across
the country I've seen it for myself and
minimum security facilities in
Massachusetts to maximum security
facilities in Georgia
these devices are smuggling to prisons
and jails to be used for hits on
witnesses scams on innocent consumers
and many other illicit purposes all of
which impact guards and inmates and all
of us ultimately I'm proud to say that
here the SEC unanimously adopted reforms
that will enable correctional facilities
to detect and to block the use of these
contraband cellphones and we're also
looking at other technological solutions
going forward outside of the rulemaking
process we also rush to the aid of
Jewish community centers and law
enforcement to help combat a wave of
bomb threats earlier this year and when
a major 911 outage hit a couple of
months ago we immediately launched an
investigation to figure out what had
happened and what could be done to
prevent it from happening again now the
last priority that I would like to
highlight is enhancing transparency and
improving the way the agency does
business long before I became chairman I
said that good process drives good
policy
as you may have heard back then I had
some problems with FCC processes one of
my favorite targets was the practice of
preventing the public from seeing a
proposal or order until after the FCC
voted on it I was told for many years it
was unlawful to change course or unwise
to do so but having spent almost five
years talking about ways we could do
things better I was eager to begin doing
things differently and we did in the
category of they said it couldn't be
done we started making the text of items
available to the public on the internet
three weeks in advance of Commission
meetings of all of the things that we've
done over our first 100 days that is one
of the initiatives that I've heard the
most positive feedback about indeed now
that we let the sunlight in it's hard to
remember why this was even a
controversial proposal in the first
place to me at least this is a useful
reminder of two things number one never
underestimate the power of government
inertia number two when the most common
defense for long-standing practices
that's just the way we've always done it
it might be a signal to think outside
the box and to begin doing things
differently speaking of doing things
differently I have long been concerned
that the economists at the agency have
not been systematically incorporated
into the FCC's policy work instead their
expertise is typically applied in an ad
hoc fashion and often late into the
process moreover the economists are
sprinkled among the agencies many
bureaus and offices well we are taking a
major step toward correcting that a
month ago i kick-started the process to
establish an office of economics and
data this office will combine economists
and data professionals from around the
FCC and I envision it providing economic
analysis for rule makings transactions
and auctions managing the Commission's
data resources and conducting
longer-term research those fame wipes
papers for instance on ways to improve
the Commission's long-term policies and
my goal is to have this new office up
and running
by the end of the year and I'd be remiss
if I didn't acknowledge the prior work
done by Jeff Isaac
Leyton mark jamison and many others for
providing the intellectual foundation
for creating this office so there you
have it a recap of our first 100 days
now obviously this is not an exhaustive
list for example I mentioned neither the
FCC's incentive auction nor my infamous
Reese's peanut butter mug but I hope I
have Illustrated at least in brief how
we intend to meet the core priorities of
this agency closing the digital divide
modernizing our rules promoting
innovation protecting consumers in
public safety and improving the agency's
operations now it's also important to
note that our accomplishments over the
first 100 days were truly a team effort
commissioners mignon Clyburn and mike
o'reilly have been critical partners in
the Commission's work for example when
it comes to closing the digital divide
Commissioner Clyburn has played a vital
role and has offered many productive
suggestions Michele Reilly has been a
leader when it comes to process reform
into easing modern read necessary
regulatory burdens that could have no
better partner than him so I would like
to take this opportunity to publicly
thank each of them for the work they
have done over the past several months
even those rare instances when we have
disagreed the exchange of our views has
made for a better ultimate work product
and of course I must thank the unsung
heroes of the FCC our amazing staff none
of what we have accomplished so far
would have been possible without their
efforts I'm well aware that many of them
have worked very long hours over the
last 100 days often under very tight
deadlines but their work has been
stellar their demeanor has been
professional and their dedication to the
cause has been unflagging and so I
appreciate all the sacrifices that they
have made in order to advance the public
interest as for me I am of course
pleased that we've gotten off to a fast
start but I would stress that's all it
is just to start a good beginning of
course is no guarantee of ultimate
success you don't believe me ask the
2017 Atlanta Falcons the 2016 Golden
State Warriors
1986 Red Sox and many other teams so
there's a lot more to do in these fields
and I'm looking forward to doing it to
building a brighter digital future for
all Americans thank you very much for
your attention thanks again to AEI for
hosting us and I look forward to
continuing to work with you in the years
to come
Thanks so we're going to engage in a
conversation here for just a couple of
minutes and then we'll turn the floor
open to questions
so one topic you didn't talk about on
your speech I'll go ahead and race just
so it doesn't go unmentioned I bet we
get a question or two about it also and
that is the open Internet proceeding I'm
not familiar with that that I've read
something about that recently so you
know without kind of getting deep into
the substance of the thing again you
know you've written on that at length
and I think the arguments are well
understood but but maybe looking ahead
at process first of all the process at
the FCC the last time this issue came
around was criticized so maybe speak a
little bit about the process as you see
it and the process reforms and how they
play into the FCC's deliberations but
then also how do you see the role of
Congress how do you see the role of the
courts in resolving you know what's
obviously a contentious issue a great
question
so first and foremost we want to make
sure that this is a proceeding that
respects the Administrative Procedure
Act and sort of basic principles of good
government and that's why it was really
important to me that the pilot project
that I announced in my second week in
office extended to all of the proposals
we would be considering including this
one and so that's why after I made a
speech where I outlined my proposal to
reform our internet regulations I wanted
to put it up on the internet immediately
and as I said at the time you may
disagree with what I proposed you may
agree with it but at least you'll be
able to see exactly what it was that I
was thinking and why and
that's really important to me because I
don't claim to have a monopoly on wisdom
I think it's important for the public to
feel like they have a seat at the table
and for the SEC to simply say this is
our plan just trust us this is what's in
it is not good enough for me as what
happened in the last iteration and so
going forward we're gonna have a very
open and transparent process following
on May 18th if the notice of proposed
rulemaking is adopted we will have
approximately three months for public
comments we've already had several weeks
of that and I think until August 16th is
the time for the public to have its say
and at that point the FCC's staff which
has dedicated as I pointed out they'll
take stock of the facts in the record
and then we at the appropriate time will
make the judgement based on those facts
and the law as we interpret it now
speaking of the law you asked about the
courts and he or - I think we're guided
of course by the decisions of the courts
have made and so I think it's important
to remember number one that the Supreme
Court's in 2005 explicitly blessed the
path that we have proposed to take in
fact just earlier this week when the DC
Circuit rejected the on bond petition
for review they explicitly say you can
see it at the bottom of page four of the
courts opinion where judge three of us
and judge Tatel
recognized that the BrandX decision
stands for the proposition that the
agency has discretion about how to
classify Internet access and so going
forward we of course want to be guided
by these legal principles and that's
something that's very important to us
you also mentioned Congress Congress of
course has very great interest in these
issues and that's why I've been doing
outreach to members of Congress on both
sides of the aisle and to both houses of
Capitol Hill to make sure that I make
myself as accessible as I can be and
people might end up disagreeing of
course this is an atopic that I
recognize as highly fraught with
political differences and policy
differences but at the end of the day I
think that a lot of the rhetoric
obscures the basic point that I've been
trying to make which is that the Clinton
administration got it right in the 1990s
the dawn of the Internet age this is not
a radical position that I've been trying
out this was the reality from the dawn
of the commercial Internet until 2015 if
you go back and look at committee
President Clinton's statement the
Internet should develop unfettered
federal and state regulation go back and
look at my predecessor chairman canard
statements that he at the crossroads of
the internet at the beginning he didn't
want to dump as he put it the morass of
title two on the internet pipe take a
look at the bipartisan statements that
we saw from many senators including
senators Wyden and former senator Kerry
where they urged the FCC not to
reclassify this new technology as a
title to service there's a reason why
they did that is because they saw the
potential of this new technology they
didn't want to import the legacy rules
from the mobile monopoly years into this
new involving service and so all I'm
simply saying going forward is that you
know I recognize that you know some
people would prefer government
micromanagement of everything internet
some people would prefer to be the Wild
West no regulation at all my approach is
pretty simple let's go down on this
middle path of light touch clinton-era
regulation it's proved to work it's
given us 1.5 trillion dollars in
infrastructure investment the internet
economy it's the envy of the world it's
a very reason that some of you at this
very moment are able to tweet out your
vigorous disagreement with whatever I
just said it's one of the great
platforms I think for democratization
and entrepreneurship and engagement and
let's just keep that going going forward
well that's thank you for that and
speaking of chairman canard and the
Clinton administration chairman canard
strategic plan from 1999 talked about
the growth of competition and he said
there you know our ability to move down
the path of a less regulatory approach
depends ultimately on some things
occurring in terms of he talked
specifically about whether DSL would
ever you know how that technology would
develop he talked highly you know
looking forward he looked I talked about
I wonder how cable modem technology will
ever develop and will that be really a
good way to get to the Internet another
part of that competitive milieu is the
question of wireless and wireline
competition right so yesterday if I
think I got this right the CDC reported
that for the first time there are more
mobile only telephone consumers that
households in the United States than
there are wired
households in the United States so my
question is I don't think you if this is
in some particular proceeding or
something you can't answer I understand
but but just as in general would you
think at this point that Wireless is a
competitor or a substitute for wireline
and the FCC might do is is the Phoenix
decision still law that's a great
question I mean to me at least they are
very competitive offerings it's if you
look at how consumers are using their
mobile devices the phone call is one of
the last things that people typically
think about now when they pick up a
phone and that's a remarkable
transformation I mean for those of us of
a certain age at least I still remember
those big phones that were hard to hold
and you make a voice call and the
quality of scratchy thought what you
know how is this device ever going to
become an integral part of life but
starting with the iPhone introduction in
2007 all the way until 2017 incredible
to see how we use these devices and you
know I look at the apps that I use every
single day it's it's amazing from fast
food to Twitter to checking my email to
you're reserving a flight or if iPhones
are some of these platforms for
innovation and so the Internet is a
critical part of that and especially as
4G LTE gets rolled out its 5g networks
with gigabit to throughput or even more
become possible as the next generation
of Wi-Fi comes onboard so we're able to
knit for instance the free up 5
gigahertz spectrum or even 1670
gigahertz spectrum for wireless
innovation I think we're increasingly
going to see that Wireless is not just
this imperfect substitute for wired
connections it is going to be the
dominant means by which people access
the Internet the preferable means and so
I think the FCC needs to take stock of
that and make the appropriate policy
decisions as a result agree I the
reference and I this just occurred to me
earlier today when I haven't looked it
up the phoenix decision was Cox applied
for deregulation in the Phoenix
marketplace MSA and this was not that
many years ago and the Commission's
decision was based on the conclusion to
deny the request was based on the
decision of the conclusion that wireless
voice cell phones were not a substitute
and as far as I know that's still law
yeah isn't it so maybe that I think
speaking please I believe is regulatory
underbrush maybe maybe we could concede
those
that's well certainly it's also
important to note that for purpose of
the title to order and yes you see had
no problem lumping wireless in with
wired no right I mean under the
well-established case of goose versus
gander I think it's important to be
consistent here and there and to take a
holistic view of the marketplace that's
I decided convergence and taken a major
step when Microsoft Microsoft calling
stopped calling the stuff on my Windows
10 operating system programs and started
calling the Maps
exactly we've converged the so another
thing that you've been active with over
the course of the past hundred and two
days is collaborating in the number of
ways with our mutual friend or enol
housing over at the Federal Trade
Commission so talk a little bit about
the FTC FCC collaboration and how you
see that playing out over time
chairwoman Olhausen has been a terrific
partner not just over the last hundred
two days but over the last several years
and I've really enjoyed the chance to
work with her on some of the issues that
have raised a lot of public attention
for example privacy she and I've
consistently said that we share the same
goal here and the goal is a consistent
and comprehensive framework that
protects consumers whenever they go
online and so I've really been grateful
not just to call her a friend but also
to rely on her as a resource to let us
know what the FTC's capabilities are
what the scope of its legal authorities
are and what the best way to secure
consumer protection in the digital age
is and so going forward that certainly
going to be the case I know that my
staff and hers have collaborated closely
as well and I'm really excited about the
chance to deliver more results on this
yeah does the FCC chairman support the
end of the common carrier exemption at
the Federal Trade Commission I think our
time is coming to a close I can't make
an official position and that's a
promise to make obviously in
consultation with the Federal Trade
Commission but that's one of the areas
with that I know chairwoman Olhausen and
even Commissioner McSweeney I believe
have golf or congressional is I was at
the FTC in the 1980s and we were pushing
for getting the common carrier exemption
so yeah so the FCC FTC would like that
well I want to stop there we've got
about 15 minutes left and we promise to
have time for questions from the
audience so I'll stop my questions there
and
the floor is open we have microphones
with staff on the sides and so raise
your hand identify yourself we'll take
the first one here and wait for the
microphone to come to you
so thank you Thank You chairman Robb
coloring at a is the investment group
you mentioned some time on the road I
was curious as to how you manage your
travel what are you thinking about
outside through the major cities and
into the rural or through the SME kind
of territories a great question thanks
for asking I love traveling throughout
those parts of the country that I went
Italy would not go as a tourist during
that same trip for instance I stopped in
zeliha nopal Pennsylvania population I
think 3812 believer not zillion opal is
sort of the hub in terms of internet
access for a big territory in western
Pennsylvania and is really useful for me
to be able to see that cable head and to
understand how that headin was trying to
deliver Internet access to hilly parts
of Western PA to see the business and
economic challenges and technical
challenges that were involved in
internet access and to be honest those
are the trips that resonate the most
with me you traveling to Dillon Nebraska
and getting to meet Chad and Courtney
lot men who used the internet to build a
beef jerky distribution company that's a
shipping nationwide it's incredible
going to Fort Yukon Alaska and getting
to see how a teacher is able to connect
with her students most of whom were
Alaska Natives and ways that were
unthinkable a generation ago visiting
Carthage Mississippi and looking at a
gigabit fiber deployment that was never
considered possible during the analog
age even going back to my hometown of
Parsons Kansas and we have seeing some
of the challenges there my own high
school for instance either Dinge apply
for great funding or didn't get the
funding that they needed in order to get
better digital services and that sort of
brought home to me at least the fact
that my own successor is at Parsons high
school weren't necessarily getting a
same opportunity some of their brethren
in bigger places and so those are the
visits that are really important to me I
grew up in a small town I grew up in
rural America however long I've might
have lived in a big city I'm still a
small-town American at heart and I'm
keenly aware that the digital divide
wrecks the greatest inequality when it
comes to smaller towns and so I'm going
forward I'm going to continue doing
those visits because the hate helps keep
me grounded and it helps keep my eyes on
the prize here which is that ubiquitous
internet access that every American who
wants it is able to get
is ultimately something that's going to
make our nation much better off I'd also
point out by the way that when I've had
a chance to talk to my international
counterparts interestingly this is the
number one priority that they talk about
as well
I met my counterpart in Nigeria for
example in February and I was struck by
the fact that he told me that 40% of
Nigerians lack internet access at all
and those are extremely poor rural
villages in particular a couple years
ago when they went to India I said in
the outskirts of a small village in
Bangalore and I saw that internet access
for poor women was extremely important
especially over their mobile phones
because that allowed them to get and
transmit money which allowed them to
start their own businesses and Columbia
I met some small startup entrepreneurs
from rural areas that we're developing
apps that allowed for instance fishermen
to be able to better communicate in
order to assess where the fish were and
try to figure out where the marketplace
opportunity was and so this is not a
American phenomenon and the other point
I'll just stress in closing is that I
when I met recently with senator angus
King outside of his office he has a
wonderful poster of JFK with a quote on
it and it says let us not search for the
Republican answer let us not search for
the Democratic answer let's search for
the right answer and notwithstanding the
political vicissitudes of you the open
Internet order or the other things that
occupy the headlines at the end of the
day I remain optimistic perhaps
foolishly so that internet access is
something we can all rally around that
all of us are better off as Americans
when we focus on that prize and rural
America at least to me is squarely and
the heart of that prize other questions
actually went in the back of the room
here
Stephen dicus I'm with the Carnegie
Endowment next door I'm wondering one of
the greatest ways to foster low-cost and
efficient internet access in new areas
is going to be through fostering
competition can you talk about measures
that might the FCC might be engaged in
to foster ISP competition specifically
and with the light touch that you're
talking about from the Clinton era means
of moderating and sharing that that is
an equal playing field for for start-up
or smaller ISPs and the larger ISP is P
companies fantastic question so here
we've been extremely aggressive as you
heard during the speech for instance
well so we have two basic tools in the
toolbox one is the wide stewardship of
the federal subsidy programs of the FCC
overseas and the other is the regulatory
framework the rules of the road that we
set for the private sector so with
respect to federal subsidies the bottom
line philosophy that I tried to apply to
these programs which I'm glad that my
colleagues have supported is making sure
that we redirect funding to the areas
that are unserved to Americans who are
off the grid altogether and make sure
they are devoted to carriers who are
committed and have been proven to be
committed to developing broadband
networks in those areas and these are
not the big companies by definition
because you don't see this big of a
return on the investment in these areas
these are some of the smaller companies
that are taking these funds and in a
fiscally responsible way applying them
to close that digital divide
additionally we've also taken a number
of other universal service actions along
those lines that just last month for
instance at our meeting we took very
arcane step which I mentioned briefly to
change our capex rules which
inadvertently stood in the way of
companies wanting to deliver high-speed
access to some of the highest cost areas
within their territory that was
perversely a way of essentially
redlining off entire rural areas from
broadband deployment so the second major
way we want to incentivize competition
is through adjusting our rules and here
I'm really excited in particular about
the impact of small wireless and wired
broadband competitors on the wireless
side for instance I've consistently said
that one of the reasons I believe so
much in five gigahertz spectrum is that
could be used by fixed wireless
lighters to be a competitive alternative
to the wired brethren and so if we were
able for instance to get 5 gigahertz
spectrum that is involves very wide
channels then they can supply very high
speeds to competitors it would be
essentially comparable hopefully do the
fixed broadband networks and especially
if you don't need to deploy all that
fixed infrastructure that you would on
the wired side that could be a pretty
important competitor especially in rural
areas with respect to the wired
competitors - we've made sure that we
take steps to relieve some of the
regulatory burdens to make it easier for
them to build a business case to compete
with the big guys so for example the
creation of the business the the
broadband deployment Advisory Committee
the B deck they're targeting ways to get
make it easier for these smaller
competitors to gain access to polls to
make it cheaper cheaper for them to
attach equipment to polls for them to be
able to get access to the conduit that's
in the ground for them to get quicker
state local approval for some of these
deployments I mean if you think about
these regulatory barriers they affect
everybody who wants to be an ISP but
especially the smaller competitors and
just give you one quick example of that
I visited with a company called rocket
fiber a small ISP a start-up bias be in
Detroit Michigan and they told me when
they've initially tried to go to the
city of Detroit to get access to the
city own polls the Detroit quoted them a
price of something like I want to say
three thousand dollars maybe in five
thousand dollars for each and every poll
and if you're a small ice pea I mean
come on you're in the city is definitely
to populate as Detroit that price is
prohibitive but negotiating new down the
price they were able to get access to
the reasonable cost to them and not
every ice piece so lucky and so we want
to reduce that cost element in order to
help the smaller competitors and moving
forward a last September I proposed my
digital empowerment agenda one critical
part of that was for Congress to give
the FCC additional authority in this
area help us create for example gigabit
Opportunity Zones which would allow us
to designate either large rural counties
or even small urban areas as it was 75%
of or less of the national median income
and in those areas we provide tax
incentives to these small companies to
provide a competitive I'm thrilled to
see the senator capita I recently
introduced legislation just this week on
that very score assembly we love for the
agent if for Congress to consider giving
us additional authority over utility
poles that are poles that are owned by a
governments and
railroads very arcane it's never going
to make the front page of any newspaper
but given the fact that this is a major
cost element for smaller competitive
ISPs that could really help us attack
that competition equation in a way that
would be good I think for consumers in
the long run
should we go here no one on the sake go
ahead wait for the mic you guys need to
step up there hi
Bill's ignorant with the Karman group
first thank you for coming and speaking
today your comments are this personal
about the robo calls yeah whatever you
do about that is great because I got one
while we were sitting here so I hope you
didn't pay up I did not but I will tell
you that one of my thoughts about that
is you should be going after the people
who benefit not the the companies that
are doing the calls but the end
beneficiaries of that so you could be
finding them and I think that'd be great
what I want to talk a little bit about
is I work with the burglar and fire
alarm industry okay very highly
competitive industry overwhelmingly
small business and involved in public
safety we're concerned that the common
carriers when they become competitors of
ours that basically they use that
control over the network to get a
competitive advantage you may be aware
there are provisions in the law that
protect us we are concerned that and
this is not a net neutrality issue what
we're concerned about is if things in
title 2 which is where we are go over to
the Federal Trade Commission by the time
we get heard a lot of our small
businesses are going to be put out of
business so the two things we would like
to see happen is one continuation under
FCC jurisdiction for at least to go on
complaints and issues and to making sure
well that's basically the major thing
we're concerned about so thanks for
flagging that concern it's been a while
since I took at the took a look at the
legal framework surrounding these issues
but I'd be happy to consider it in the
meantime please do file a either in an
existing proceeding or if there's
petitioner applications because it only
applies basically to landline modernize
like I said I'd be happy to take a look
and so I definitely send some paper our
way and I'll do you want us to carve out
some time to take a look at it we have
time for one more question probably
we've had the left it's time for the
right right left we trying to I got one
right back here yes sir wait for the mic
please not the far right this is the
moderate right ha ha David hat what is
the deal reporter so the the previous
FCC did not look favorably at reducing
the number of nationwide wireless
carriers from four to three and given
the statements that you just made about
the level of competition is that a
possibility that you be open to I take
the role of the my approach to the
regulatory role is one of humility that
I don't claim to know in a vacuum what
the optimal market structure of any
particular marketplace is what the right
number of competitors should be our goal
is always to make sure that the
marketplace functions in a way that
benefits the public interest and so to
me at least we take a look at the
marketplace as it stands try to figure
out is there competition our prices
going down or his application and
service innovation going up those kinds
of things and then make the appropriate
judgment for instance through our
Wireless Competition report if any
transaction is presented to us the
framework I've applied and I've
consistently applied going back to my
statements on November 30th the 2011
when I was a nominee was that we always
evaluate transactions based on the
public interest standard now figuring
out whether the consummation of that
transaction would be good for
competition and consumers and make the
appropriate judgment thereafter and
that's the framework I'm going to play
going forward if we're presented with
any
transactional reviews I'm told we'll
take one more and I saw one more hand
over thought it was someone hi good one
more here
we haven't liked you yes here we go
behind the fellow with a stylish Fedora
yeah Marya backs with morning consult I
was just wondering if you can talk a
little bit more about I don't know if
this is related to the federal subsidy
you were talking about earlier but um a
commissioner Clybourn I had suggested
that the way that the universal service
fee is funded right now is unsustainable
since it's coming mostly from landline
phones you just talked a little bit
about that and how federal subsidies
will be collected in the future if there
are changes today sure so to the folks
who are blissfully unfamiliar with this
area the Universal Service Fund is
funded by essentially a tax that is on
every phone bill that a consumer pays
and so if you look at your bill you see
Universal service fee those fees go into
essentially a pot of money that the FCC
oversees therefore different Universal
service and programs one of which I
mentioned today the high cost program
for delivering broadband to rural
America and unserved America so the yet
that fee is something that varies over
time the FCC and it's the company that
overseas for administering this program
this program make a determination about
what that contribution factor is it's
called should be and there's an their
existing bodies to determine whether the
fee should be adjusted right now my
colleague Commissioner O'Reilly is the
chair of a what's called a joint board
that oversees of these issues and
they're squarely tackling that question
so we haven't the this discussion has
been ongoing for quite a while and we
haven't made any determinations yet so I
hate to pass the buck to my good friend
but since he's the chairman of that
relevant joint board I would have to
defer answering were you're free to talk
to him if you like about that question
process reform in action I know I feel
like God did posing homework of my
colleagues it's been wonderful having
here you learn something every time I
always learn something when I listen to
you today I learned something I didn't
expect that you'd spend so much time in
prison yeah so it's it's as I've
listened on your CV but thanks for
letting us know voluntarily I hate that
I was watching him listen thank you so
much for being here I asked everyone to
join me in thanking do you also stay
seated as much after officiating oh okay
what a great forum to I love
[Applause]
you